Okay so the object today is to
wrap our arms around,
not all but a good portion,
of the material covered.
The book called,
Bottom Billion,
is somewhat neglected in
today's discussion but should
not be neglected in your essays.
Indeed, your essays will need
to take account of many of the
things said by Paul Collier in
that book.
First of all,
our topic slide here,
you have to ask yourself first
what this guy believes that
umbrella is going to do for him.
It's--and I'll show you the
subsequent slide in the
appropriate place about what
happens next,
but the gist of that slide is
that capitalism is a dynamic
system which is always leaning
forward and is always within a
few months of leaning too far
forward.
It is the nature of the system.
Okay I'm going to begin by
revisiting the fundamentals,
these systems of ideas that we
began the term with,
and then we'll look at some of
those system in greater detail.
Thomas Malthus,
Essay on Population,
the thesis is that nearly
universal poverty is inevitable,
because wherever productivity
increases,
population increases apace,
and the resources used for
production have diminishing
returns as you invest more and
more labor.
Malthus is obviously thinking
about farming,
and farming in a small island
called England,
and he's wrong.
The world demographic
transition utterly contradicts
his theory,
and the fact that birth rates
and death rates might fall in
the precipitous way they did is
the world demographic transition
and is a major key to why the
world economy works the way it
does,
because it produces an enormous
surplus of labor in the
societies which pass through it
later rather than earlier.
Similarly, if we look at Hans
Rosling's wonderful data
animation which we used on the
first day of class relating life
expectancy to GDP per capita,
the world in the last 120 years
has grown richer on average five
or six fold,
500% or 600%,
richer and healthier,
longer lived so that there is a
human project,
a world human project in which
the best of capitalism
participates,
and I think that's the
important upside to the topic.
Adam Smith, "invisible
hand," and Smith has become
in death a more famous figure
than he was in life,
and a simpler figure.
The number of people who have
actually read Wealth of
Nations or read it and
Theory of Moral Sentiment
is a tiny fraction of the people
who claim to organize all their
thinking around Adam Smith,
and Adam Smith's invisible hand
is a fragile thing which
operates not with giant
corporations,
not with oligopolies,
not with monopsonies,
it operates under conditions of
perfect or near perfect
competition.
And the Porter Forces which we
have seen,
direct competition,
the threat of new competition,
the threat of people moving to
substitute products,
the power of suppliers and the
power of buyers to bargain,
all five of those factors work
against the invisible hand.
The whole point of the Porter
Forces is how business
corporations avoid being
compelled to behave in the
Smithian way of producing goods
and selling them at or near
their marginal cost.
Carl Marx and Joseph Schumpeter;
two great economists,
two great thinkers,
Marx the founder of a
revolutionary movement,
Schumpeter a banker,
a Harvard professor,
a brilliant intellect;
two ways of looking at the same
thing.
What these two guys agree on is
that capitalism is an inherently
unstable forward-moving system.
That the one thing of which
capitalism is incapable is
standing still,
that like the bicyclist in my
title slide,
capitalism always leans forward
and always relies on events in
the future which are not
predictable.
Now where the two part ways is
that Marx is a determinist;
Marx really thinks that he can
foretell the history of
capitalism in its main outlines.
And he was mistaken;
of that we can be sure.
Schumpeter, on the other hand,
believed that the future of
capitalism is inherently
indeterminate.
That there is much random
process, so much opportunity for
unexpected innovation,
that the prediction of
capital--the behavior of
capitalist economies,
beyond the very short term,
is impossible,
and I'm inclined to believe
that Schumpeter's right about
that.
Hayek.
Hayek is the guy who wrote
Constitution of Liberty,
and it's possible to be very
critical of Hayek,
who does play some logical
tricks with his reader.
On the other hand,
he puts forward a passionate
vision about the creative
possibilities of a free society.
A society in which the right to
innovate the right to choose,
the right to author ones own
life and propose scripts for the
lives of others;
a society which is open and not
subject to overbearing hierarchy
and bureaucracy is a learning
machine,
and Hayek is a brilliant
theorist of that learning
machine.
Another set of fundamentals,
this is Ronald Coase,
he of Coase theorem fame.
This is Hernando de Soto,
he of Mystery of
Capitalism fame,
and what they both say is that
capital formation relies on
governments and courts,
and the formalization of
property rights,
and that one of the
foundational aspects of our
wealth in the western world is
tradable property rights so that
our houses are also small
storehouses of capital,
and our earning power can be
the collateral for debt which is
repaid through future earnings.
That whole aspect of
capitalism, that whole metabolic
process is at the fundaments of
the best aspects of capitalism,
the aspects that involve
sustained prosperity.
Okay with the remaining forty
minutes of our class,
I'm going to go through these
topics, you can just take a
quick glance at them.
They are basically the details
of what I've just adumbrated,
and the last of them is the
case for your final.
Okay capital,
capital is accumulated wealth
reproductively deployed.
It can take the form of
cultivated land,
it can take the form of seed
corn, it can take the form of
factory machinery,
it can take the form of stock
certificates,
it can take the form of
educated people;
indeed, in a very real sense
you are in the process of
capital formation during your
years as university students.
You will be an embodiment of
capital,
and indeed, capital of a high
order when you finish Yale
College or the School of
Management,
or the law school,
or whatever may be your last
stop.
Capitalism, on the other hand,
is the name that socialists
gave to a whole bunch of things
they didn't like.
Private businesses that,
in their view,
exploited labor,
in their view despoiled the
environment,
in their view desanctified
historical and religious
tradition,
and there is no inventor of
capitalism.
Adam Smith didn't use the term,
Adam Smith didn't even like
joint stock corporations;
he thought they generally
didn't work well,
but it is an organic system,
which develops over time,
and as Hayek and Schumpeter and
others point out to us,
is capable of self-modification
through time.
Marx's historicist theory of
this,
and we did a whole lecture on
this in September,
with the idea that capitalism
always turns toward monopolies
that capital becomes too
abundant,
and the rate of return on it
falls with time,
that the working class is
eventually starved out,
eviscerated to use the term,
the inevitable revolution in
advanced capitalist systems.
The places the revolution
occurred were always in the
least advanced market societies,
places like the Soviet Union.
The theory of a universal
class, that once the working
class captures society there
will be no class below it,
and therefore,
no possibility of conflict and
exploitation,
the withering away of the state.
Well here are the places where
the revolution occurred in red,
and it occurred in almost all
of them because the capitalist
order was not developing and not
maturing,
rather than that it was
developing and had exhausted
itself.
The withering away of the state
takes awhile.
This is from the Communist
Manifesto,
and this is where he gets it
right.
The notion that the
bourgeoisie, that is
capitalists,
cannot exist without
constitution--constantly
revolutionizing the process of
production,
that the conservation of old
ways of doing things was
characteristic of every previous
economic system but not of
capitalism.
"All that is solid melts
into air.
So the flat part of this is
pre-capitalism,
this is the Angus-Madison Curve
that Clark in his Farewell to
Alms uses as his thesis
again,
and again, and again.
And the upturn corresponds to
the capitalist era.
Now it also corresponds to the
era of intensive use of fossil
fuels.
It also corresponds to the era
of radical urbanization,
and it also corresponds to a
period of extraordinarily fast
technological innovation,
and you can say that I give
capitalism too much credit,
and I'll settle for agreeing
with that.
But I will also say that
capitalism is a--
has within it,
endogenously,
enormous incentives for
continuous technological
innovation and for the rapid
deployment of desirable
technologies,
and in that way it differs from
all other systems.
Capitalism during its rule of
scarce 100 years has created
more massive and more colossal
productive forces than have all
preceding generations together.
That's a true statement.
It was made in the winter of
1847-1848 and it was arguably
true then, it is vastly more
obviously true today.
That in roughly ten
generations, maybe twelve
generations,
capitalism has created more
total wealth and total spending
power than all the economic
systems which occupied human
history before that time.
Now Gapminder,
I'm actually in a little bit of
a--
I don't really have time for a
Gapminder exercise,
but there it is,
gapminder.org,
just go and play it.
Play it for yourselves if you
want to be sure that we're not
talking about something
imaginary.
Now what an interesting
exercise to do is to single out
some command economies such as
the Soviet Union before it--
in 1989, or Cuba throughout the
last sixty years and watch them,
and what you'll find is they do
relatively well on the health
and longevity dimension and not
so well on the GDP dimension.
It is perfectly reasonable for
someone to say,
"I don't care about
wealth.
I care about health and good
spirit and all that,
and I'm not interested in being
part of a society that generates
enormous wealth,"
and there are very reasonable
and rational people who take
that view.
It's an option and its fine,
it's even admirable,
but it's not what capitalist
market societies are about.
One reasonable critique of
capitalist market societies is
that they encourage us all to
consume way beyond our real
needs.
That we spend more money on
clothing and automobiles and
sporting equipment,
and liquor than is really
needed, and there's no doubt of
that.
I'm guilty myself,
and my guess is that most of
you feel the pull of market
society and the inclination to
spend more than would be
absolutely rational or
necessary.
Fair enough;
it's a critique,
and I think it's a valid one.
The state, property,
and capital;
back to Smith.
Smith famously talked about the
night watchmen's fate,
the state which focuses
primarily on law and order,
and the enforcement of
contract;
the state which makes it
possible for a person to own
property,
to deploy that property
productively,
and to make money by satisfying
the apparent needs of others.
Now in order to have a night
watchmen state you better have a
state,
and Smith wrote roughly two
centuries,
a century and a half,
after the Treaty of Westphalia
1648,
which was the launch point of
the modern nation's state system
with a monopoly on force and
violence,
and Smith is in a sense
building a theoretical system on
the foundation of state-enforced
property rights.
In fact, not just in a way,
that is what he does.
These are the states involved
in that treaty.
This is Thomas Hobbs whose
Leviathan is the defining
tract on nation states,
and which defines the leviathan
as a monopolist on force and
violence.
We prevent being the victims of
one another by entrusting to the
state a full monopoly on the use
of force and violence,
and in that way,
profit enormously through
peace,
security, and the ability to
plan ahead based on our current
property holdings.
The nation state system lays
out like this.
It is in many ways,
I think you can say this
definitively,
capitalism without the nation's
state system is infeasible.
That if there were not the
coercive agency of the state in
the background to vouch safe
property and contract,
to perform the functions de
Soto attributes to it,
if it were not for that,
then none of the capital
formation processes that are
vital to our wealth would be
reliable and feasible.
Now you could invent some
entirely different system.
You could invent a system which
sliced the world on another
angle, conceivably a functional
angle, or could be a gender
organization in the world.
There could be a state for
women and a state for men,
the geography of it would be a
little tangled but they're going
to reproduce,
but the gist of this is that
capitalist wealth rests on the
foundation of the nation state
system and the nation state
system is not altogether a
pretty story.
Here's the British Empire as it
stood in 1920,
or the 1920s,
and none of these places shown
in red volunteered to join the
British Empire.
Now you might claim that
Australia and New Zealand did,
I think, but even that's a
reach.
The British Empire was an
extremely coercive device for
occupying territories and
extracting from their economies
a vast surplus for the
metropolitan country.
It had many knock on effects
which worked out well.
The--much of the infrastructure
and educational systems which
makes India so promising today
is partly related to the best
parts of British raj,
but the colonial background is
a part of the nation state
story.
The function of states having
no state versus a state,
having a failed state versus an
effective state,
having a state which fails to
promote formal property versus
one that does,
the one point in the tree which
leads to the existence of what
de Soto calls live capital is
this one,
and lucky for you and me,
it is the one which envelops
our lives in the United States
and in the western world.
The--and de Soto's thesis
really boils down to this
two-by-two table with dead
versus live capital,
and formal versus informal
property rights,
but in the back of this is the
notion that you have to have a
state which effectively and
efficiently administers
property.
And that means an elaborate
court system,
a vast number of lawyers,
barristers,
and the like,
a huge recordkeeping system,
and a--and behind it all a
government capable of enforcing
property rights against theft
and expropriation.
This map of this neighborhood
of New Haven,
the green lines are the
property lines,
and the vault at 200 Orange
Street contains the records
corresponding to each of the
green polygons,
and in the city there are
26,000 and some green polygons
like that,
and the whole surface of North
America is covered with
analogous polygons which are
seed points of capital
formation,
and energize the economy.
Now de Soto constructs a
strategy of conversion from dead
capital to live,
toward the back part of the
book with these phases
indicated,
and in many parts of the world,
in much of Latin America,
much of Africa,
some parts of Asia,
the campaign to create live
capital is a very real and live
campaign today,
and is strategically of
considerable importance.
As you think ahead to the case
you're going to write about,
in Cochabamba,
Bolivia, and about which we'll
have a few minutes to talk
toward the end of this class,
the very informality of that
economy is part of what kills
Bechtel and its development
projects.
De Soto makes quite a lot of
how it is that you can't have an
informal system of property and
then just impose,
cookie cutter style,
a formal system of property
which no one understands,
and which doesn't correspond to
their beliefs.
You've got to adapt the formal
system to the informal system,
and if de Soto is right and I
think he is,
part of the brilliance of
American property law was that
it found ways to incorporate
again,
and again, and again to
incorporate informal property
rights like the Tomahawk farm,
or the miners' rights recorded
in miners' association records
having no relationship to
government.
Government didn't come along
and say,
"No that's all baloney,
we're going to do it our
way," government came along
and said,
"Oh we see,
now let's put that into
language which can be
incorporated in the law,
and which can allow the law to
work with rather than against
the property rights which you
have established among
yourselves.
Ron Coase, Coase is a Chicago
School economist and a--
and he's written--he wrote all
kinds of wonderful scholarship,
and what's called the Coase
Theorem is really post hoc
reinterpretation of his work.
He never sat down to write a
paper called "my
theorem,"
and the insight in it is really
pretty straightforward,
and I make it a little simpler
than he would like it.
But as we said before,
where there are clear initial
entitlements,
where the entitlements and the
opportunity to change them are
transparent,
and where the information is
shared in a way that is
relatively symmetrical so that
we don't have situations where a
buyer or a broker knows all
kinds of things which a customer
doesn't know--
I said that wrong--where an
owner or a broker knows all
kinds of things which a customer
doesn't know;
and finally,
low transaction costs.
A practical story;
have any of you ever been
involved in a buying a house or
being part of a family as it
bought a house?
Yes.
Okay, that's informative.
Did you--what did you do to
remedy the information asymmetry
between you and the seller?
Student:  I didn't do
anything.
Prof: You didn't do
anything, but what did your
family do?
Student:  Visited the
house.
Prof: Okay and just that?
Student:  I'm sure they
had all sorts of papers but--
Prof: I hope what they
did was hired someone to inspect
the house and give them a
report.
Let's check with the
gentle--behind you.
Do you have experience with
this?
Student:  Yes.
Prof: And--
Student:  We had it
appraised.
Prof: Okay you had an
appraisal.
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: And did you have
anybody look at the pipes,
and the roof,
and the--and all that?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: Good I'm glad.
The--there's a--I say this
because I,
four or five years ago bought a
house with a slate roof and I
got a report which called the
condition of the slate roof
"very good."
Well it turns out that
"very good"
for a slate roof costs about
$20,000 a year in repairs,
so it was a very bad decision
on my part,
but the information symmetry
part of this is central and the
idea is that you can get
efficient market,
including an efficient
formation of capital through
leveraging real property where
those conditions are met.
So as a practical guide in
doing things you get three
things to tick on your fingers
and think about in managing the
affairs of an organization or a
firm.
This is too complicated;
the rough idea here is to take
the three factors in Coase and
run them against the obvious
aspects of the nation state
system and look how--
take an example technology
transfer relates to transparency
so that where one segment of
society has unique access to
technology and knowledge that
others lack,
you can assume there will be
huge asymmetries in the
distribution of information and
that that will distort the
functioning of the economy,
and sure enough it does,
and part of the justification
for government provision of
public education is that it
provides the minimum access to
information and the methods of
obtaining information which are
required by citizenship in a
democratic and market society.
With any market economy you're
going to expect to move
northeast of the status quo.
I did an elaborate exercise
with Edgeworth boxes with you
about a month ago,
and where you start determines
where you end.
So if we start here,
where the Smith's have almost
everything, we're going to end
up somewhere up there.
Or here where the Joneses own
almost everything,
we're going to end up somewhere
here.
So what Coase doesn't say is
that there is some particular
symmetry or justice to the way
property rights move,
and indeed, it's worth stopping
to say that to ourselves.
Whomsoever expects social
justice from a market economy
expects in vain.
That's not what market
economies are good at,
they're good at a lot of
things, but you cannot when you
are a wealthy septuagenarian,
and I'm at least one of those
two, you cannot say to yourself
that it is the just verdict that
the American economy that I
should be well to do.
It has in it all kinds of
happenstance factors,
including the luck of one's
birth, and the generosity of
one's educators that those
things happen,
and so the claim I--people,
I am clearly pro-capitalist,
but when I argue with people
and they say,
"Well you know there are
all kinds of people who have
more money than they deserve and
others who have less,"
I say,
"Yes, I agree,
and there may be other remedies
you want to take for that."
For example,
giving some people some of your
own money, but the claim for
capitalism just doesn't go
there.
Wealth maximizing law and the
joint stock corporation;
the law that government creates
can either be well designed or
poorly designed to create
wealth, and we started some
months ago with Ghen v.
Rich, the matter of a
sinking whale and the tailoring
of the judgment in that case to
preserve the incentive for the
whaling industry,
by allowing the principle gains
to go to those who take the
largest risks and make the
largest investment and that's
the intuition of wealth
maximizing law.
Another case we I think looked
at, I'm not quite sure,
did we do U.S.
v.
Cosby, the one about air
rights?
Well you get it.
Before the airplane it was
perfectly sensible to say that
the air rights over one's land
extended to the end of the
universe,
or at least until they got to
the next inhabited solar system.
That was a perfectly okay thing
to say and did no harm,
but once air travel became part
of the technology,
it had to change that precept
and grant the right of free
trespass above a certain
altitude.
This is Marc Lanier;
did I show you guys a little
bit of Marc Lanier?
Okay and the dark side of
wealth max--the top side of
wealth maximizing law is tort
law and the lawsuit.
But the thinking behind having
lawsuits is that lawsuits
provide an incentive against
carelessness in dealing with the
lives of others and the
punishment that a company gets
for producing a hazardous
product or performing a risky
and failed medical procedure is
a way of keeping manufacturers
and healthcare people honest and
careful.
The critical features of the
joint stock corporation,
as compared with
straightforward proprietorship
and partnership,
are first of all that the chain
of accountability is thin.
That is the customer's and
investors;
both have only a thin
relationship with the decision
makers in the firm.
If you owned 1,000 shares of
General Motors and you think
they shouldn't have fired Fritz
yesterday,
as they did,
you're going to waste your
money by calling them up to talk
about it.
If you're the owner of a
General Motors car and you don't
like the way the door handles
are put on,
it's not much use calling them
up and asking them to do it
differently.
What you have to do is buy
another manufacturer's car.
The role of ownership is
passive.
The investors buy shares and if
they don't like the course of
the company's management they
sell the shares.
Liability is limited;
the most that an investor can
lose is what she put into the
shares that she purchased,
and that's a great provision
right.
If you're an investor it means
that you really don't have to do
much homework,
at least homework about the
downside of management
practices.
Liquidity is like water.
It is a perfectly liquid
instrument and it is an
endlessly scalable instrument,
and the joint stock corporation
is about--
between 88% to 90% of a market
economy is embodied in joint
stock corporations.
Whenever there are flaws,
and their flaws are many,
Jim Alexander here has told you
of a few,
their flaws are many but the
ability to produce at enormous
scale,
with enormous efficiency,
is very real.
I'll post these slides so you
don't need to write down all my
squiggles.
But the most important feature
is that you've got centralized
management which has a thin
relationship both with customers
and with investors and is--
and has the capacity to engage
in efficient production of stuff
people actually want to buy.
Vertical integration is a key
feature of companies like this,
vertical integration meaning
that the company engages itself
in a long chain of activities
which start,
in the extreme case,
start with raw materials.
For example,
iron ore in the ground,
tobacco growing in the field,
lobsters crawling about under
Penobscot Bay and finishes with
lobsters on the plate,
with a completed automobile or
whatever,
and vertical integration
creates an enormously difficult
management challenge,
and often companies wisely walk
away from some aspect of it.
The car companies,
for example,
have been shedding the
manufacture of many of their
intermediate parts now for
thirty or forty years because it
was so difficult to manage.
But the advantage is that it
gives the company enormous
autonomy from others who seek to
intervene in its operations.
The vertically integrated
corporation is also,
from a public perception point
of view, quite often a monster.
Alex, I think it was,
referred us to the picture of a
vampire squid for Goldman Sachs
and that picture actually goes
back--
this is an 1881 cartoon of
Standard Oil pictured not as a
vampire squid but as a giant
squid with tentacles reaching
into everyone's living room and
it was that.
Vertical integration from an
olive grove to Palmolive Soap,
that's the gist of this.
The slogan on the Palmolive
Soap, "I learned from a
beauty expert how to hold my
husband."
That's a terrible way to sell
people soap.
That is just wrong.
It just is.
But marketing does that and
it's part of the package in a
capitalist market society.
The first great corporations
were the American railroads,
or at least in American
history, and the Alfred Chandler
piece about the Pennsylvania
railroad is a good example of
this.
They involve enormously large
scale investment of capital in
the railroad infrastructure in
rolling stock,
and they created a challenge to
management which no previous
business had created.
So you've got 50,000 employees,
and you've got these enormous
contraptions running at one
another all over the place,
and incidentally,
in the early years killing
5,000 or 10,000 people a year
and the management of all that
required one of the great
revolutions,
which I have spent little time
on in this course,
where in the joint stock
corporation,
you've developed a huge cadre
of professionally trained
managers,
like the crowd sitting back
right, soon to be freshly minted
Yale MBA's who are going to
run--
I don't think they're going to
run trains,
but they're going to run big,
complicated things.
Goldman Sachs is a different
kettle of fish.
Goldman Sachs is not vertically
integrated at all.
It occupies a strategic
position in the economy which
allows it,
economy and government,
which allows it to create--
to use enormous leverage and
enormously high powered
expertise to generate revenues
on a more or less unprecedented
scale,
and Paolo Zanonni is my very
dear friend.
He really is,
I mean we're really good
friends, but I would say--I
would say it to his face.
I probably wouldn't say it in
front of 100 people to his face,
but I would say it to his face
that he earns way too much
money,
just outrageous how much money
he earns.
Now I wouldn't invent a law to
take his money away but I do
think that there's more of it
than he needs or deserves,
but like I said capitalism
doesn't solve that problem.
This is the inner courtyard at
Infosys in Bangalore,
in India, and the process of
very rapid formation of gigantic
wealth in--
through the best joint stock
corporations is a worldwide
event and the world would be a
better place if there were more
of it.
The Ibbotson slides which I
showed you some months ago,
for the U.S.,
summarized what becomes of a
dollar invested in 1927 as
common stock and that kind of
growth is characteristic only of
very well managed equity
investments.
Greater possibilities with free
society;
Hayek conceives a society as a
learning machine,
and the score of knowledge and
institutional practices which
are built up in a market
society,
build up in an exponential way
like the green curve here,
and the most important fact
about that is that no individual
knows a very high fraction of
the total knowledge of the
system.
We are all--we all need to be
self consciously humble about
how little it is we know about
the total operation of the
system.
We are all looking at 1%,
3%, 2% of the data which make
our society function or fail to
do so.
That condition,
it's more and more obvious,
right?
If you think about what it is
that is on the screen in your--
on your study desk,
what's accessible on that
screen at any given moment is
thousands of times more than you
will ever command.
I'm going to have to stop there
with that and go back and go to
the case,
because I want to have time for
that,
and I'll post--I've got three
or for more topics there but
I'll post the slides and I want
to discuss the case with you.
Of--can we turn this--how many
of you were able to look at the
Finnegan piece so far?
Got your attention, good;
you ought to start by--I would
start interpreting this story by
asking yourself about Bolivia's
history in social composition
and where it fits in the world
economy.
How it relates to Paul
Collier's Bottom Billion
and here's one obvious way it
relates.
Collier has a series of what he
calls traps, if you run Bolivia
through all the traps you will
see that it is not a favored
nation.
It is a nation which has many
vulnerabilities,
and it is consequently on the
lower edge of the world economy.
Now, it has a city called
Cochabamba, about 800,000 people
with a water company called--a
water agency called Siempas and
that agency is terrible.
It does a very poor job of
delivering water.
It is also corrupt and a very
high fraction of the water
distributed is distributed
illegally,
people tap into it,
just as in poor countries
people tap into the power cables
that run through their areas.
The--there are two gigantic
agencies,
The World Bank and The
International Monetary Fund,
which believe in markets in a
big way,
and they have pressured Bolivia
and fifty or seventy-five
similar bottom billion countries
to marketize their economies
through private investment.
And the gist of the story is
that the investment of private
capital will incentivize
companies,
typically well financed joint
stock corporations,
to do an awful lot better job
of providing water,
electricity,
rail service,
air service,
all the basic functions of an
economy will be better performed
privately than the were
publicly.
The people who are--the
inspirers of that are called The
Chicago Boys,
a group of young economists,
the most famous of whom is
Jeffrey Sachs,
who was then at Chicago but is
now at Columbia,
and the market tonic is what
was applied in this case.
Now the case didn't work,
the tonic didn't work and one
conclusion is that market reform
is altogether wrong and will
fail everywhere.
I think you can gather some
evidence through your reading
and through Collier one way or
the other on that point.
The gist of the question,
which I'll post tomorrow,
is explain what happened when
Bechtel,
through its wholly owned
subsidiary,
went into Cochabamba to
re-conceive,
reconfigure,
and reconstruct the water
system.
Interpret that story in light
of the most important things
you've learned in this course.
Are there questions?
Okay we'll see each other again
on December 14,
at the exam.